The SCP Foundation faces off against a number
of incomprehensible, impossibly dangerous
threats every single day.
They’ve gotten so used to containing terrifying
monsters and world-ending anomalies that it’s
really just all in a day’s work for them.
But what if there was something that scared
even the most jaded Foundation personnel?
Something that none of them could track, understand,
or even see?
In the 1990s, employees of the SCP Foundation
began to disappear without a trace.
At first, the higher-ups assumed it was traumatized
personnel making a break for it after they’d
seen something that finally made them snap.
But that wouldn’t account for all the blood.
At the site of every disappearance, the last
place anyone saw the missing person before
they were gone, there was a massive amount
of blood left behind.
Not an “I cut my thumb while chopping onions”
amount of blood, but an “I’m missing a
limb” amount of blood.
Buckets and buckets of what was confirmed
to be the missing person’s blood were found,
spilled all over the scene of their disappearance.
The first recorded instance of this phenomenon
was captured via security footage of a laboratory
late at night.
There, Dr. Porter was sat in his lab chair
finishing up some tests, running potentially
anomalous soil samples through a variety of
machines.
The room was mostly dark, save for the light
of a small desk lamp.
Suddenly, he looked up from his work, eyes
darting around the room.
He couldn’t see anything, but he could feel
it: there was something in there with him.
He couldn’t shake the feeling that something
horrible was about to happen, and, not about
to stick around and see what it would be,
he made a break for the door.
Just before his outstretched arm reached the
handle, he jerked back into the room as if
pulled by the back of his hair.
He looked around wildly for his assailant,
but there was nothing there that he could
see.
The security footage showed him jerked around,
thrashing his arms as he tried to fight off
an invisible attacker for several seconds.
Then, he was gone, and the pristine white
tile of the laboratory was smeared with that
tell-tale bright red.
He wasn’t pulled into a pocket dimension
like an attack by SCP-106.
He was simply there one moment and gone the
next, the blood on the ground the only sign
he had ever been there at all.
Dr. Porter’s disappearance was troubling,
but the Foundation hoped it might just be
an isolated incident.
Of course, nothing ever goes the way you’d
hope when you’re dealing with SCPs, and
within the next six months, three more personnel
had vanished in the same way.
The phenomenon, whatever was causing it, had
a few simple rules it seemed to play by: it
occurred on a cycle of 1 to 3 months, it only
happened to Foundation personnel, and it always
happened in a dark place where visibility
was limited.
Understandably unsettled, many personnel stopped
coming into work, afraid they might be next.
Unfortunately for them, the phenomenon was
not limited to the area within the Foundation’s
walls.
It could find them no matter how far they
ran, as soon as they were in the dark.
You can’t fight, outrun, or outsmart the
setting sun or your bedside lamp going dead.
Research Assistant Sanchez vanished while
taking a shortcut down an alley at night.
Doctor Costanza was taken while she was reading
a book before bed.
Her blood-stained sheets, discovered days
later, indicated she didn’t even have time
to run.
Junior Researcher Watanabe disappeared from
the back row of a midnight screening of Evil
Dead 2.
Moviegoers at the same screening reported
hearing some commotion from the back, like
someone hitting one of the seats and kicking
their legs.
but they assumed it was just a massive Bruce
Campbell fan excited about the movie.
The noise only lasted for a few seconds, anyway.
And so the pattern continued, and every couple
of months one member of the Foundation staff
vanished, leaving behind only blood and a
sense of dread.
None of the missing staff, dead or alive,
were ever found.
The phenomenon was assigned the designation
SCP-835-JP, and, though they tried to come
up with a plan to contain it or put a stop
to it, many accepted it as simply another
occupational hazard in an increasingly long
list that came with doing the Foundation’s
work.
Just when it was beginning to look like there
would never be a way to prevent new brushes
with SCP-835 short of never being alone in
the dark ever again, something weird and wonderful
happened.
In a Japanese SCP Foundation facility, during
one of the phenomenon’s inactive periods,
a booklet entitled “Artist’s Impression
of SCP-835-JP” was found on the desk of
a research assistant.
It depicted a fictional character known as
Keteru Yamiko, intended to be a personification
of the phenomena.
Keteru Yamiko, as depicted in the booklet,
is a young woman drawn in a traditional anime
and manga art style.
She is pale, with blue eyes and long black
hair, and is dressed in a classic Japanese
school uniform.
In addition to her design, the booklet also
described the character’s abilities and
backstory.
Keteru is described as a type of assassin,
with expertise in predatory ambush.
A santoku knife is her weapon of choice.
She also displays anomalous abilities with
regard to the absence of light.
She is able to manipulate darkness, and use
dark and shadows as a weapon that she can
trap her targets with.
She is also able to teleport using shadows,
transporting herself, objects, or her prey
through shadows to remove all evidence of
what she has done.
The origins of Keteru’s abilities are somewhat
murky, but whether she was born with them
or given them, she came into her unusual talents
at a young age.
Due to her abilities, she was found by a mysterious
organization, an unknown enemy of the SCP
Foundation, and abducted by them as a child.
There, they indoctrinated her and trained
her to be a master assassin, teaching her
how to use her abilities, master hand-to-hand
combat and the use of weapons, and to have
the ice-cold demeanor of a perfect killer.
She learned to move in the shadows and make
darkness her ultimate home and ally.
Once her training was complete, Keteru was
sent out into the world with one mission:
To take out members of the SCP Foundation
by any means necessary.
According to the lore of the booklet, her
killings drew the attention of the Foundation,
though they did not understand who she was
or who had sent her.
Then, they assigned her the designation of
SCP-835-JP.
The booklet was sent to the site’s head
researcher, who brought in the assistant for
further questioning.
The man confessed to having drawn the booklet,
saying that drawing Keteru Yamiko had made
him feel less afraid of the mysterious entity.
By turning it into a fictional character,
he was taking his sense of control back as
well as turning his fear into a chance to
explore his favorite hobby, drawing.
What had once been a completely unknown enemy,
something without a face or a motive of any
kind, was now a classic anime character and
something he could wrap his mind around.
Also, he just thought it all looked really
cool.
He was reprimanded for drawing on the job
and making light of a phenomenon that had
taken so many of his colleagues, he was transferred
to a different department, and the booklet
was largely forgotten about.
At least, until one researcher, Dr. Sato,
noticed something curious.
After the discovery of the Keteru Yamiko booklet,
also known as Incident-835-JP, there were
no disappearances for five months.
Another disappearance finally occurred, but
the pattern, which had been so consistent
before, was disrupted for the first time in
a decade.
Dr. Sato noticed this delay, and, though his
colleagues mocked him for it, drew a connection
between the longer inactive period and the
discovery of the Keteru Yamiko booklet.
He quickly got to work, and developed and
proposed Protocol Idol-835, which was approved
by a head researcher desperate for some kind
of solution, and promptly put into practice.
Dr. Sato’s theory behind the implementation
of Protocol Idol was that, somehow, SCP-835-JP
was connected to and influenced by the perceptions
of the Foundation personnel.
In fact, it had likely originated from their
collective sense of anxiety and paranoia in
the first place, acting as a tulpa, or a thought
made real through intense concentration and
belief.
Therefore, he hypothesized that by changing
the staff’s perception of the phenomena
from something horrifying and unknowable to
an approachable and even fun fictional character,
they could somehow contain it and stop any
further disappearances.
The goal of Protocol Idol was to create a
shared version of SCP-835-JP for all of the
staff to focus on, stripping the entity of
its original power.
Since many staff had already seen the original
Keteru Yamiko booklet, she was chosen to be
the shared, agreed-upon description of SCP-835-JP.
With all of that decided, the Protocol was
officially put into place.
First, all of the documents and reports that
referred to SCP-835-JP were edited to include
details about Keteru Yamiko, including descriptions
of the character, repeated mentions of her
name instead of the SCP’s number, and various
illustrations.
In addition to changing the records, a publicity
campaign was mounted to cement the idea of
Keteru Yamiko in the minds of all of the staff.
Keteru Yamiko’s design was painted on various
supplies, on the side of transport vans, on
the doors to laboratories, and as murals on
several walls throughout the facility.
The booklet was copied and distributed around
the facility as a piece of required reading.
The original author of the booklet was brought
back on board to design and head the creation
of a variety of other reading materials, including
fictional novels, manga, and short animated
videos featuring Keteru Yamiko as the main
character.
Mandatory watch parties were held for these
short animations, and free snacks and drinks
were provided in order to boost morale.
Several employees began jokingly referring
to these watch parties as “SCP Foundation
Anime Club.”
Through the efforts of the Idol Protocol,
the image and knowledge of Keteru Yamiko spread
throughout the Foundation and became the dominant
perception of SCP-835-JP.
Since the implementation of this protocol,
there have been no disappearances in line
with SCP-835-JP’s pattern, and the project
was declared a success.
Dr. Sato included this note in SCP-835-JP’s
file: “SCP-835-JP is probably a manifestation
of the instinctive fear that something threatening
oneself may be lurking in the darkness.
But the imaginary monster we once feared has
now been reduced to a clichéd character with
Protocol Idol-835.”
Ever since the implementation of Protocol
Idol-835, SCP-835-JP is considered neutralized.
Its classification has been downgraded from
Keter to Safe.
There have been talks about strengthening
the entity’s containment by expanding the
protocol outside of the Foundation, in order
to prevent the possibility of containment
breaches down the line that might be brought
on by exposure to a major cognitohazard or
in-house amnestics.
A special team of illustrators, animators,
and writers has been brought on to spearhead
the protocol, creating additional comic books,
posters, and even beginning the early stages
of production on a feature-length animated
film about SCP-835-JP and her various exploits,
tentatively titled “Keteru Yamiko: Shadow
Girl”.
There have been no plans made yet for international
distribution, but who knows?
We might just see Keteru Yamiko on the big
screen one of these days.
She might just end up as the first ever SCP
to become a mainstream celebrity.
And until then, the Foundation could also
disseminate knowledge about her through other
means.
Say, a fun little animated YouTube video.
But what’s the chance they’d ever pull
a move like that, right?
Now go check out “SCP-2935 O, Death and
More Epic SCP Stories You Can't Miss” and
“Procedure 110 Montauk REVEALED - Fear Alone
- SCP-231 Tale” for more mind-bending anomalous
action from the SCP Foundation!